- de séance à tous l'ordre du jour
appelle la discussion du projet de loi
relatif à l'agencé nationale des voies
navigables dans la discussion générale
la parole est à madame nathalie
kosciusko morizet ministre de l'écologie
du développement durable des transports
et du logement
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les les sénateurs monsieur le
président monsieur le rapporteur ou
discuter aujourd'hui du projet de loi
relatif à voies navigables de france
c'est une traduction concrète une
nouvelle traduction concrète des
engagements du grenelle de
l'environnement en matière de transport
et il est le résultat d'une volonté
partagée j'y reviendrai celle de tous
les acteurs concernés de renforcer le
transport modal le report modal vers la
voie d'eau et de faire évoluer la part
du non routier et du nom aérien il
s'agit de passer de 14 % à 25 % pour le
non routier et non aérien d'ici 2022
certains de nos voisins les allemands
les néerlandais les belges ont misé très
tôt sur la voie d'eau en matière de fret
et la france point son tour aujourd'hui
la formidable mesure du potentiel de
développement du transport fluvial
les excellents chiffres de trafic de
fret notamment en 2010 avec une
progression de +2 8% témoigne de ce
regain cette vigueur retrouvée des
montres l' impossibilité la faisabilité
d'aller plus loin pour la première fois
depuis les années 70 le transport de
fret par voie d'eau a dépassé en 2010 et
8 milliards de tonnes kilomètres sur une
année ce projet de loi mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs vise à rattraper
notre retard par rapport à nos voisins
européens peut être à les dépasser à
contourne à dessiner en tout cas les
contours du mode fluvial de demain et il
est né sait
r pour ce faire de modifier en
profondeur l'organisation du service
public de la voie d'eau je leur dit
grenelle 1 donné au transport fluvial à
caractère prioritaire
le programme prévu par la loi grenelle 1
par exemple avec la réalisation du canal
seine nord europe et la régénération du
réseau magistral l'organisation aussi
débat public sur les nouvelles liaisons
à grand gabarit a permis au transport
fluvial de franchir une nouvelle étape
ceci dit le canal seine nord europe
n'épuise pas la question et
l'optimisation du service public de la
voie d'eau n'est pas optimale c'est de
cette dernière qu'il est question
aujourd'hui l'établissement public
industriel et commercial créé en 91 pour
exploiter entretenir améliorer
développer promouvoir les voies
navigables voies navigables de france ne
maîtrisent pas ou jour d'aujourd'hui
tous les moyens indispensables à sa
gestion il exerce par exemple qu'une
autorité limitée sur des agents pourtant
certains agents ces agents lui sont
entièrement dédiés ils sont
indispensables à son bon fonctionnement
l'établissement ne contrôlent aussi que
très peu sa propre organisation
territoriale et puis surtout l'état des
lieux du réseau impose la mise en place
rapide urgente d'amélioration une
réforme du service public de la voie
d'eau pour tout bon et nécessaire
nous avons besoin en effet pour répondre
aux défis que ce site est au début d'un
réseau moderniser et fiabiliser mais
nous avons aussi besoin d'une
organisation plus efficace en confiant
la responsabilité du tout à une entité
unique
c'est pourquoi la principale disposition
du projet de loi consiste à transformer
voies navigables de france en un
établissement public administratif de
l'état il regroupera les 400 salariés
actuels de vnf et les 4500 agents des
services déconcentrés de l'état qui
aujourd'hui travaillent de fait
entièrement pour lui et ce rapprochement
permettra d' instituer une véritable
communauté de travail unifié les
compétences et les moyens au sein d'un
nouvel établissement au service de la
voie d'eau concrètement le projet de loi
donne désormais au directeur général de
l'établissement autorité sur toutes les
catégories de personnel de
l'établissement fonctionnaires ouvriers
des parcs des ateliers des bases
aériennes de l'état les agents
contractuels de droit public les
salariés régis par le code du travail
le directeur général aura également des
compétences en matière de rémunération
de gestion de recrutement et de
formation pour lui permettre de
développer une politique d'emploi adapté
pour aboutir à ce projet
thierry mariani et moi même avons mené
une large concertation avec les
représentants des personnels du
ministère et de voies navigables de
france tant sur le contenu de la réforme
que sur le contour du nouvel
établissement et il en est ressorti un
consensus sur le développement de la
voie d'eau à laquelle les personnels
sont extrêmement attachés c'est un
métier de passion ils en ont tous
témoigné de par leurs engagements par le
passé et de par leur engagement aussi à
l'occasion des discussions que nous
avons mené cette concertation était
indispensable pour définir les garanties
à apporter aux agents nous avons ainsi
veiller à ce que projet de loi
garantisse à chaque catégorie d'âge en
le maintien de son statut ou la
conservation des stipulations de son
contrat nous sommes aussi attaché à ce
que le regroupement des instances de
gouvernance de concertation de
représentation des personnels au sein du
nouvel établissement tient compte de la
diversité des salariés et cette vision
partagée nous a permis de signer un
protocole d'accord avec la majorité des
organisations syndicales
c'est sur la base de ce dernier qu'est
fondée le projet de loi qui vous est
soumis aujourd'hui le gouvernement
je lis ou également ici est très
attachée au respect des équilibres qui
ont pu être trouvées dans le cas de
cette concertation afin de permettre
d'offrir de vraies garanties à la
concrétisation futur d'une véritable
communauté de travail qui fait toute
l'ambition de ce projet doit second tu
as peur du projet de loi
c'est de renforcer les missions
d'établissement pour affirmer sa
contribution à la réalisation des
objectifs du grenelle le développement
de la voie fluviale en complémentarité
avec les autres modes de transport c'est
un objectif qui vise prioritairement le
grand gabarit ça veut pas dire que le
réseau touristique et oublier le réseau
touristique comme l'indispensable prise
en compte des préoccupations
d'aménagement du territoire sont bien
présents et je sais à quel point le
sénat et vous mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs est attaché ces problématiques
dans le projet de loi renforce les
missions historiques entretien
exploitation développement de la voie
d'eau de l'établissement en confortant
son rôle en matière de développement
durable et d'aménagement et territoires
et il prend notamment en compte la
diversité de vocation de la voie d'eau
comme réseau transport qui soient dédiés
au fret ou au tourisme
le rôle de l'établissement en matière de
gestion hydraulique est également
renforcée pour prendre en considération
les enjeux liés au partage de la
ressource en eau et je sais que ça aussi
son importance pour vous ça mange pas
enfin dans la perspective d'accroître
les ressources de l'établissement et lui
permettent de valoriser le domaine de
l'état qui lui est confiée le projet
doit lui confère des compétences
nouvelles pour exploiter à titre
accessoire on est bien d'accord ce n'est
pas son objet principal
l'énergie hydraulique des cours d'eau au
moyen d'installation ou d'ouvragés situé
sur le domaine public fluvial
il s'agit de mettre au service de la
voie d'eau est motivée l'opérateur qui
l'a gérera des ressources qui lui seront
extrêmement utiles
mesdames et messieurs sénateurs nous
venons de fêter l'anniversaire de voies
navigables de france
ce sont ces 20 ans à 20 ans il était
temps que nous en faisions un
établissement disposant des leviers et
des moyens qui lui permettront d'aller
encore plus loin et d'atteindre les
objectifs du grenelle de l'environnement
dont je parlais tout à l'heure les
ressources que je viens de citer ne sont
naturellement pas les seuls sons
quelques ressources nouvelles qui disent
des choses je crois sur notre ambition
mais pour mettre en oeuvre ses objectifs
ambitieux semant hab volume financier
l'établissement disposera ainsi de
moyens supplémentaires pour moderniser
restaurer sécuriser le réseau
concernant le grand gabarit
l'objectif est d'ouvrir la navigation 24
heures sur 24 c'est ce que font déjà nos
voisins du nord c'est une des clés de
leur succès s'agissant du réseau
touristique
il s'agit de mettre en place une offre
de services adaptée qui tiennent compte
de la saisonnalité de ce secteur et la
réalité des besoins la mise en oeuvre du
programme d'investissement de vnf aura
également un impact important et positif
sur les conditions de travail des agents
notamment en matière de sécurité au
travail
les barrages manuel par exemple seront
progressivement remplacés parallèlement
alors remise en état des équipements de
sécurité des ouvrages pour tout ce
programme l'état a décidé d'attribuer à
l'établissement des ressources
supplémentaires c'est par exemple
l'augmentation de
axe hydraulique vous l'avait votée l'an
dernier elle devrait apporter 330
millions d'euros en année pleine
ces ressources sont affectés entièrement
financement d'un plan d'investissement
qui en tous ses 840 millions d'euros sur
les années 2010 à 2013 c'est un niveau
jamais atteint depuis la création de
l'établissement
ces moyens additionnels sont un gage de
réussite de la réforme est une
démonstration une illustration
supplémentaire de nos ambitions en la
matière mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs au monde conclure mon propos
et sans préjuger des améliorations vous
voudrez apportés à ce projet de loi je
souhaite que nos débats
sa tâche a dégagé la meilleure
organisation possible du service public
de la voie d'eau je le redis vingt ans
après la création de vnf ce texte est
une étape essentielle crucial dans le
développement de la voie d'eau que nous
sommes très nombreux ici a appelée de
nos voeux
ce texte et fondateur d'une nouvelle
ambition pour la france je disais nous
pouvons rattraper nos voisins du nord
nous pouvons les dépasser nous avons
besoin tout ça d'un opérateur renouvelée
avec des nouvelles compétences des
nouveaux moyens une nouvelle
organisation comme le demandait le
grenelle le gouvernement a tenu dans le
respect et l'écouté de l'ensemble des
acteurs concernés à faire de ce texte
l'assise d'une ambition renouvelée je
suis sûr que vous la partagerez et je
vous remercie de votre attention
merci madame la ministre
la parole est à monsieur francis grignon
rapporteur de la commission de
l'économie du développement durable et
de l'aménagement du territoire
merci monsieur le président madame le
ministre mes chers collègues pour
examiner ce projet de loi le travail en
commission s'est déroulée dans des
conditions particulières puisque j'ai
été désigné votre rapporteur provisoire
le 7 septembre et confirmé le 27
septembre
donc j'en profite pour remercier les
présidents et les membres respectifs de
la commission qui m'ont fait confiance
dans les deux cas de figure ce projet de
loi vise pour l'essentiel à regrouper
dans un même établissement public
les 400 salariés de voies navigables de
france vnf et les 4400 agents de
services de l'état qui travaillent pour
les voies navigables car depuis sa
création en 1991 l'état a confié à
l'établissement public vnf la gestion de
la plus grande partie du domaine public
fluvial mais en gardant les services de
la navigation dans le giron du ministère
vnf et donc donneur d'ordre mais il n'a
pas d'autorité hiérarchique sur les
services de la navigation
on appelle ça en termes de management
l'autorité fonctionnelle et tout
gestionnaire sait combien ce système
gène l'action vingt ans après le
gouvernement propose mettre fin à cette
organisation inhabituel
c'est d'autant plus bienvenu est
nécessaire que l'heure est à la relance
de la voie d'eau pour atteindre le
report modal fixés par le grenelle de
l'environnement ce projet de loi était
négocié avec les organisations
représentatives des personnels concernés
pendant six mois
les négociations ont abouti au début de
l'été dernier à la signature de deux
documents cadres l'un pour les agents
publics et un protocole d'accord a été
signé le 24 juin par la cgt la cfdt
l'unsa
seule fo a voté contre pour les salariés
du privé un accord-cadre est acceptée le
1er juillet par la cfdt qui est la seule
organisation représentative du personnel
de vnf te disent ces accords d'abord que
l'établissement public industriel et
commercial vnf devient un établissement
public administratif un epa dénommé
agence nationale des voies navigables
ensuite que les voies navigables demeure
la propriété de l'état que les avantages
individuels et collectifs des agents
publics et des salariés du privé sont
préserver leur emploi bien sûr mais
également leurs avantages statutaires
aux contractuels individuel et collectif
ces accords précise également qu'aucun
agent ne se verra imposer mobilité
géographique
ces accords affirme enfin que la relance
de la voie d'eau concerne toutes les
voies navigables et pas seulement celle
dédiée au fret
on comprend dans ces conditions pourquoi
l'acceptabilité sociale du projet a put
être majoritairement obtenus nous sommes
nombreux cependant à constater le
décalage entre l'ampleur du travail à
accomplir pour développer nos voies
navigables et la focalisation si étroite
de ce texte
tous les grands sujets d'aménagement du
territoire en sont absents
puisqu'on ne fait ici que changer la
gouvernance de vnf en fait c'est dans le
schéma national des infrastructures
terrestres snit et dans les budgets
successifs que nous aurons une première
réponse à la problématique des voies
navigables en france pour l'heure je
pense qu'il vaut mieux faciliter
l'effort entrepris en acceptant ce texte
même partiel et en l'améliorant quelques
mots quand même sur la problématique de
nos voies navigables je ne tournerai
personne en disant qu' elles sont
souvent en mauvais état et qu'ils sont
peu adaptés aux frais de contemporains
non voies navigables sont parmi les plus
longues d'europe avec 8500 km mais leur
gabarit est insuffisant notre réseau
manque de cohérence et les équipements
sont généralement très mauvais état
faute d'entretien et ce depuis des
dizaines d'années
dans la compétition logistique entre la
route le faire hello l'avantagent
économique des voies navigables commence
à partir d'un certain seuil de
massification c'est quand elles peuvent
faire circuler des pénis de plus de 650
tonnes que les voix sont dites à grand
gabarit et qu'elles peuvent être alors
compétitif pour le transport or sur
l'ensemble de notre réseau à peine 20%
de nos voies navigables atteignent ce
sol de grands gabarits
songez qu'en allemagne c'est 70% des
voies navigables qui sont à ce grand
gabarit
on comprend pourquoi une autoroute
fluviale relie le port de rotterdam à
duisbourg en allemagne d'où partent
chaque jour une centaine de trains en
direction du reste de l'europe
qui plus est ne voie d'eau à grand
gabarit sont mal reliées entre elles
elles sont enclavés dans nos grands
bassins c'est tout l'enjeu du canal
seine-nord dont nous allons reparler que
de rallier le bassin de la seine au
reste de l'europe par la voie navigable
nos grandes voies d'eau enfin manque
d'entretien
dans le rapport qu'il nous a remis en
avril dernier sur l'état de nos voies
navigables le gouvernement constate lui
même que le réseau est vieillie usée et
il chiffre la modernisation des seules
voies à grand gabarit à 2,5 milliards
d'euros dont 1,2 milliard pour la simple
remise en état
on comprend dans ces conditions les
difficultés du report modal depuis dix
ans le fj est le fret fluvial progresse
de 9%
chaque année grâce en particulier aux
conteneurs mais sa part dans le trafic
global est stable en dessous des 4 %
c'est dire que nous avons du chemin à
faire pour atteindre l'objectif
intermodal du grenelle pour le seul fret
fluvial il faudrait doubler ce trafic
d'ici 2018
l'intérêt de nos voies d'eau cependant
vient bien va pardon bien au delà du
secteur du transport
nous redécouvrons que nos voies
navigables sont une chance pour notre
pays
elles sont importants pour l'accès à
l'eau potable pour l'industrie pour
l'agriculture
nos barrages et les réservoirs sont
utiles dans la prévention des
inondations ou encore en cas de
sécheresse les voies d'eau prennent de
la valeur dans la vie quotidienne de nos
concitoyens
on ne compte plus les aménagements de
berges et des programmes de rénovation
de quais dans les villes témoin de cette
découverte des plaisirs du fil de l'eau
et de la qualité de vie au bord d'un
canal nos voies navigables enfin sont un
facteur d'attractivité important pour le
tourisme dont la france se glorifie
d'être la première destination mondiale
en d'autres termes le gestionnaire de la
voie d'eau d'eaux bien sûr se soucier du
trafic fluvial mais il participe à une
mission bien plus large d'aménagement
durable du territoire
cette mission implique peu ou prou les
collectivités publiques dans leur
ensemble état et collectivités
territoriales et nos concitoyens ils
sont très attentifs le gouvernement pour
atteindre l'objectif intermodal du
grenelle investi dans le flux viable
l'idée d'une relance de la voie d'eau
n'est pas nouvelle
c'est même celle qui a présidé à la
création de vnf
il y a vingt ans par le gouvernement de
monsieur rocard le renouveau fluvial est
un fait européens déclaré monsieur
delebarre ministre de l'equipement
l'état confié alors vajou est la gestion
de son réseau à l'epic vnf en lui
affectant une taxe nouvelle la taxe
hydraulique qui représentent aujourd'hui
plus des deux tiers de ressources de
l'établissement public l'état cependant
à laisser son établissement public bien
seul pendant de longues années
songez qu'il a fallu atteindre attendre
pardon la fin 2004 pour que l'état
formalise une stratégie dans un contrat
d'objectifs et de moyens alors que la
loi de 80 ans prescrivait la définition
d'un document stratégique pour cadrer
l'action de son établissement public
c'est donc seulement dans les années
2000 que la relance doivent la voie
d'eau a pris la consistance depuis le
grenelle de la vie de l'environnement
les choses s'accélèrent il y à aussi
l'annnonce du canal seine-nord pour 2019
qui ouvrira la voie sur l'europe du nord
dans ces conditions vnf a défini en 2010
un programme très ambitieux d'un montant
global de 2 5 milliards sur la décennie
ce programme comprend des
investissements pour élargir les
gabarits moderniser les barrages et les
écluses ouvrir les voies principales 24
heures sur 24 comme chez nos voisins
belges allemands et hollandais l'état
concentre donc ses efforts sur le fret
fluvial compétitif c'est dire sur les
voies à grand gabarit avec en ligne de
mire l'objectif du report modal défini
par la loi programme de grenelle les
moyens suivront ils je crois que nous
pouvons tous reconnaître que les
investissements progressent du début des
années 2000 à aujourd'hui le rythme des
investissements a quasiment doublé
nous sommes passés de 100 millions par
an à 185 millions d'euros l'an passé et
vnf compte investir 200 millions cette
année
il y a eu le plan de relance qui
apportait 50 millions annuels de 2009 en
2009 et 2010 pour cette année nous avons
voté une augmentation de la taxe
hydraulique en loi de finances qui
devrait rapporter 30 millions
supplémentaires et l' agence de
financement des infrastructures
contribuera pour 40 millions les régions
contribuent également dans le cadre des
contrats de plan état région pour la
période 2010-2013 les crédits
contractualiser représente un peu plus
de 20% des investissements programmés
par edf ce rythme encourageant qui
correspond programme de vnf pour les dix
ans à venir sera-t-il tenu
il est bien sûr difficile de le garantir
mais les engagements tenus à ce jour me
paraissent justifiés
notre entrée entier soutien pardon à
cette entreprise le programme de
modernisation de notre réseau à grand
gabarit est enfin lancée il faut le
soutenir
je crois donc et c'est ainsi qu'il nous
faut comprendre ce texte
nous allons par les établissements
publics institutions représentatives du
personnel modalités de transfert des
personnels en cas de décentralisation
des voies d'eau mais c'est que le
souffle de ce texte vous l'avez compris
et ailleurs le gouvernement investit
pour la voie d'eau et il agit dans ce
texte
avec ce texte technique pour lui donner
les chances les meilleurs d'arriver à
bon port ce qui ne nous interdit pas
bien entendu d'améliorer ce projet de
loi sans entrer ici dans le détail la
commission a apporté des améliorations
sur quatre questions premièrement nous
avons maintenu le nom de vnf à
l'établissement gestionnaire des voies
navigables depuis 20 ans vnf a acquis de
la notoriété en particulier auprès de
ses clients et les agents des services
de la navigation utilisés même vêtement
de travail les véhicules siglés vnf dans
ces conditions le maintien du nom nous
est apparu de bon sens et de bonne
gestion
deuxièmement nous avons élargi et
préciser les missions d'établissement
public
le gouvernement propose un établissement
public administratif
pourquoi parce que vnf après le
regroupement contrat 93 % d'agents de
droit public eux et parce que 85 % de
ses ressources proviennent des
subventions et de taxes mais aussi parce
que les agents des services de la
navigation ont manifesté leur préférence
pour un ep 1
il y voit une garantie pour leurs
emplois nous devons donc assuré
cependant que ce statut n'empêche pas
l'action de l'établissement
celle de développer la voie d'eau ce qui
a une forte composante industrielle et
commerciale
c'est pourquoi la commission a accepté
de confier à cette paix à des
compétences qui relèvent généralement de
l'epic le législateur peut tout à fait
composé l'établissement public qu'il
estime le plus souhaitable pour
l'objectif visé il est même le seul à
pouvoir le faire
nous tenons ce pouvoir de l'article 34
de la constitution
il implique que nous définissions les
grands principes et que nous donnions
les indications au pouvoir réglementaire
pour les respecter en conséquence la
commission a accepté que vaine
puisse conduire des opérations
d'aménagement pour valoriser le domaine
public fluvial y compris en créant des
filiales et en prenant des
participations dans des sociétés et
groupements
nous avons établi un lien plus direct de
ses opérations avec l'émission de vnf
cependant nous débattrons l'article
premier de deux conditions
supplémentaires
celle d'un capital majoritairement
public pour les filiales et les sociétés
vnf aura recours est celle d'une
concertation des collectivités
territoriales
toujours sur l'émission nous avons tenu
à lever toute ambiguïté sur le fait que
l'état conserve bien une compétence
générale sur les voies navigables non
transférées aux collectivités locales
nous avons complété bien évidemment la
mission de gestion hydraulique en
précisant que les élèves devrait
concilier les usages diversifiés de la
ressource aquatique et assurer
l'entretien comme la surveillance des
ouvrages et des aménagements
hydrauliques
nous avons inclus la conservation du
patrimoine dans l'émission de vnf
troisièmement du patrimoine afférents à
vnf bien sûr
troisièmement nous avons recherché
accompagner au mieux le regroupement des
agents de droit public et des salariés
de droit privé
ce texte prévoit que vnf contrat dans
son personnel les agents de droit public
et des salariés de droit privé de
manière pérenne c'est reconnaître que la
communité du fluvial a deux composantes
l'une est public l'autre et privés et
les deux partagent le même objectif
celui de développer les voies navigables
dès lors nous avons adopté une rédaction
indiquant clairement au pouvoir
réglementaire que chacune de ces deux
composantes doit pouvoir s'exprimer
collectivement dans le fonctionnement
ordinaire et pérenne de vnf
ce principe a des répercussions très
précises sur les nombres de
représentants du personnel au conseil
d'administration et sur les institutions
représentatives du personnel
nous y reviendrons amplement dans
l'examen des article
quatrièmement enfin nous avons tenu à
éviter tout empiètement de ce texte sur
les accords passés
entre l'état et les collectivités
territoriales sur le transfert de voies
navigables la décentralisation des voies
dites secondaires est un enjeu très
important
ce texte contente de préciser que les
transferts à venir qui reste facultatif
se feront depuis vnf et non depuis
l'état cependant cette modalité
technique ne pas ne doit pas être
défavorable à cordes expérimentation
passé à ce jour comme c'est le cas pour
la région bourgogne
la commission a précisé le texte pour
s'en assurer
monsieur le président madame rémy nice
mes chers collègues ce texte technique
est limité dans son objet me paraît donc
utile indispensable même à la relance de
la voie d'eau même si bien sûr il n'y
suffira pas à lui seul les pouvoirs
publics engagent un effort financier
sans précédent depuis des décennies
vnf n'a pas ménagé sa peine pour
orchestrer la relance les agents de la
communauté du fluvial sont mobilisés à
porte pour l'heure notre soutien je vous
remercie
eh bien merci monsieur le rapporteur
dans la suite de la discussion générale
la parole est maintenant à monsieur
daniel dubois au nom du groupe de
l'union centriste et républicaine
le président madame la ministre monsieur
le représentant de la commission des
affaires économiques de l'aménagement du
territoire et du développement durable
monsieur le rapporteur
mes chers collègues mon intervention
madame la ministre va commencer par une
question finalement était il nécessaire
etait-il nécessaire de changer le statut
de vnf pour rassembler sous une même
bannière et c'est nécessaire évidemment
quelques 5000 personnes qui oeuvrent
pour les voies navigables endroit la
réponse est non
endroit la réponse est non il n'y a pas
d'obstacle juridique à ce que des agents
publics intègre un établissement public
à caractère industriel et commercial en
opportunités non plus d'ailleurs
dans ce domaine en opportunités non plus
à l'heure où le gouvernement cherche
plus de souplesse dans sa gestion
administrative
il aurait eu intérêt à ce que les futurs
employés de vénès les futurs employés de
l est systématiquement un contrat de
droit privé dans l'image que renvoie le
statut de vnf j'aurais naturellement
souhaité le maintien du statut d'epic
car c'est bien une mission industrielles
et commerciales que réalise vnf la
logique économique doit d'ailleurs
dicter la cohérence de la gestion du
domaine public fluvial et notamment de
ses investissements stratégiques pour le
développement du fret fluvial et
multimodal mais on en parle assez peu
malheureusement il reste dans ce texte
sur le rap auteur l'a souligné ça a été
soulignée en commission des affaires
économiques
nous nous considérons que c'est tout à
fait dommage on avait une opportunité
pour
renforcer cette approche alors le
changement de nature et je vais en
terminer le changement de nature de
l'établissement et donc pour moi et pour
le groupe que je représente ici une
contorsion plus qu'une nécessité
évidemment du coup on fait rentrer
artificiellement dans un établissement
public administratif des missions et des
financements propres aux établissements
publics industriels et commerciaux
faisant finalement de vnf
en l'occurrence une structure ad-hoc et
j'ose dire un bâtard ceci étant dit ceci
étant dit madame la mine sourit oui oui
j'assume bien sûr évidemment évidemment
madame la ministre
ceci étant dit il me semble toutefois
opportun de souligner l'intérêt
l'intérêt est évident à rassembler les
salariés sous une même bannière
on est là dessus je serais tout à fait
d'accord
une même bannière un même commandement
et je crois d'ailleurs que la plupart
d'entre eux doutent partage cette
réforme de bon sens en effet jusqu'à
présent vnf ça a été dit tout à leurs
employés 3 169 salariés de statut privé
4000 cas d' utiliser 4014 agents des
services déconcentrés de l'état mis à sa
disposition par le ministère chargé des
voies navigables le le personnel relevé
à la fois de l'autorité fonctionnelle de
vnf et de l'autorité hiérarchique du
ministère ce qui posait évidemment des
difficultés de gestion de
responsabilisation du personnel et une
modernisation de l'établissement
cette réforme nous semblons tout à fait
nécessaire elle donne à vnf une
structure managériale plus solide plus
visible lui permettant de mener plus
efficacement ses missions de
modernisation et développement des voies
navigables et il faut dire que dans ce
domaine il ya effectivement du travail
donc sur l'objet même nous sommes
d'accord c'est plutôt sur la le montage
juridique les voies fluviales navigables
ont longtemps été délaissées
elles font l'objet d'un sévère sous
investissement dans l'entretien et
l'exploitation de ses quelque 2000
ouvrages écluses barrages appartenant à
vnf en conséquence notre réseau fluvial
n'est pas compétitif aujourd'hui alors
même que le trafic de conteneurs explose
le réseau fluvial nationale dispose de
réserves de capacité importante et
pourrait recevoir trois à quatre fois
plus de trafic selon les sections
concernées
alors à l'instar de nos façades
maritimes nous avons de l'or bleu entre
les mains et nous n'en faisons pas
j'allais dire assez raide pour le
développement dans ce domaine même si le
gouvernement
et c'est vrai à engager des réformes de
fond qui était nécessaire je pense à la
réforme des ports mais il est donc
urgent d'entreprendre
aujourd'hui la modernisation et le
développement du réseau et de réaliser
des plateformes logistiques multimodales
sur le domaine public fluvial
cela permettrait l'accroissement du
trafic fluvial des chantiers d'ampleur
doivent être engagées selon une
stratégie bien définie
ainsi nous pourrons nous approcher de
l'objectif du grenelle d'amener le fret
non routier de 14 à 25% 15 ans et il
aurait été à ce propos souhaitable
monsieur le ministre que le gouvernement
inscrive ses objectifs dans le projet de
loi et nous regrettons seulement donc de
regrets le premier la forme juridique
qui génère un bâtard la deuxième le
manque d'ambition ça a été dit mais
monsieur le rapporteur l'a dit tout à
l'heure alors c'est pour cela que nous
soutiendrons un amendement j'irai qui va
dans ce sens qui a été déposé parce
qu'il nous paraît tout à fait cohérent
le texte aurait dû prendre en compte je
dirais cet enjeu alors au vu de
l'ampleur de la modernisation des voies
fluviales à entreprendre
on peut se féliciter on peut se
féliciter d'une part que le nouvel
établissement conserve ses leviers
financer
de péage et de taxes et d'autre part que
l'état finance la dot de la mariée à
hauteur de 840 millions d'euros
le réseau en a effectivement bien besoin
je ne doute pas qu'ils seront bien
utilisés et seront reconduits et seront
reconduits pour que le schéma national
des infrastructures de transport que
l'on a adopté en début d'année puissent
tenir ses promesses
en outre en outre monsieur minutes je
souhaite attirer l'attention du
gouvernement sur l'intérêt à mieux
associer les collectivités dans le
fonctionnement de lagence il nous
faudrait réfléchir par exemple à une
ouverture du conseil d'administration
plus large aux élus des collectivités
pour améliorer le dialogue entre vnf et
les collectivités de même
l'opacité de nombreuses décisions de
police de l'eau à multiplier les
contentieux ces dernières années et
élargir ce serait vraiment souhaitable
et si c'était pas le cas qu'il y ait au
moins un médiateur qui amène à pouvoir
régler les problèmes en relation avec
les collectivités concernées
il ya un vrai une vraie problématique
sur ce sujet enfin enfin monsieur le
ministre on a modernisé dans la
perspective de modernisation du réseau
de fret fluvial et en tant qu'élu de la
somme
je souhaite saluer l'engagement du
président de la république bah oui
m'attendais mais quand c'est la réalité
il faut le dire et a causé la réalité
mes chers collègues vous pouvez pas
défendre je ré les voies fluviales et ne
pas noter que si le canal à grand
gabarit seine nord europe démarre c'est
bien parce qu'il ya une volonté du
président de la république c
un incontournable nous en tous les cas
dans le nord et dans la somme on le sait
c'est évident c'est évident que s'il
n'avait pas décidé de lancer le ppp
le dialogue compétitif sur le sujet ça
ne démarreraient pas et c'est un enjeu
majeur à la fois d'amélioration et notre
présence dans toute entière de notre
pays aurait pour la prise en compte du
ray du développement du fret fluvial
c'est incontournable en reliant le nord
de l'europe devrait au grand bassin
parisien
ça ça va permettre de transporter de
l'ordre de 13 à 15 millions de tonnes de
marchandises soit l'équivalent de 500
milles poids lourds par an 500000 poids
lourds par an il faut quand même le
préciser
sur l'un des corridors de transit les
plus empruntées d'europe paris amsterdam
vous l'aurez compris monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues le groupe
de l'union centriste et républicaine
soutient donc le projet d'ensemble dédié
à vnf en dehors y aurait des deux points
que j'ai soulevé tout à l'heure à la
fois la forme juridique
emprunté et le manque peut-être de
souffle par rapport à l'enjeu
stratégique est vrai pour la nouvelle
structure bon et j'espère que le nouveau
statut
je l'espère vraiment ne fera pas
obstacle au développement industriel et
commercial attendu par les territoires
et les entreprises
et je vous remercie de votre attention
merci mon cher collègue la parole est
maintenant à monsieur philippe s nole au
nom du groupe socialiste et europe
écologie les verts
monsieur le président madame la ministre
je crois qu'elle est partie monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission chers collègues c'est le
rapporteur se coller le projet de loi
que nous présente le gouvernement et que
nous examinons aujourd'hui est un texte
important et je suis très heureux en
tant que sénateur récemment élu dans les
yvelines 2 mètres vu confier la charge
d' exprimer la position du groupe
socialiste sur un tel sujet en effet
nous voterons dans quelques minutes sur
une série de mesures techniques mais
essentiel pour l'organisation et les
conditions de travail de presque 5000
agents 4400 agents publics de l'état et
400 agents privés employés à ce jour par
voies navigables de france
il s'agit de permettre à l'ensemble de
ses agents de pouvoir mieux travailler
ensemble à la promotion et
l'exploitation du réseau fluvial
français en les regroupant au sein d'un
même établissement
nous verrons au cours de notre
discussion si les conditions sont
remplies
dans une telle perspective mais c'est à
ces femmes et à ces hommes qui
travaillent chacune et chacun au service
de notre pays qu'il nous faut d'abord
penser au moment d'examiner ce texte
ensuite de manière plus générale le
projet de loi s'insèrent bien évidemment
dans une stratégie plus globale des
sorts du trafic fluvial particulièrement
du transport de marchandises et du fret
qui est je veux le dire une impérieuse
nécessité pour notre pays ayant accumulé
un grave retard en termes
d'investissements publics et
d'infrastructures depuis deux déjà de
trop nombreuses années sur ce sujet je
commencerai par là vous ne trouverez
chez les socialistes d allier la
promotion du trafic fera le trafic
fluvial est une préoccupation que nous
partageons sans réserve avec évidemment
nos amis écologistes
la france est dotée de pas moins de huit
milles 500 km de voies navigables
or nos routes sont saturés notamment par
le trafic de marchandises et le report
modal n'est plus une simple option il
est devenu une nécessité
le grenelle de l'environnement dont nous
partageons largement les objectifs mais
nous devons nous déplorons
malheureusement les moyens souvent
insuffisant le grenelle de
l'environnement fixe en ce domaine un
chiffre clair
portée de 14% à 25% la part cumulé du
fret ferroviaire et fluvial dans le
transport de marchandises
il y aurait beaucoup à dire et à redire
sur la manière dont la politique de fret
de la sncf est réduite à la portion
congrue les fermetures de gares de
triage l'absence de volonté politique et
la frustration des cheminots sont
suffisamment parlants mais ce n'est pas
la note du jour concernant le fluvial
l'enjeu consiste tout simplement à
doubler le trafic actuel est un objectif
que nous pouvons atteindre temps nous
sommes en retard aujourd'hui on regarde
nos possibilités en retard par rapport
aux grands ports fluviaux du nord de
l'europe comme rotterdam où bruges en
retard surtout en termes
d'investissements publics
songez que nos infrastructures fluviales
ont été modernisées pour la dernière
fois dans les années 1920 par le
programme précis mais il nous faut
passer à une nouvelle étape du transport
fluvial et remettre en état un réseau
qui ne répond plus aux normes
internationales accroître les capacités
les gabarits du réseau principal assurer
la sécurisation des voies garantir la
mise en conformité environnementale du
réseau de son exploitation permettre
aussi l'essor du réseau secondaire dans
les domaines du tourisme des loisirs et
de la plaisance qui sont réellement
porter au niveau local sur tous ces
sujets nous considérons qu'il fait faire
confiance à voies navigables de france
et lui donner les moyens d'agir dans le
sens notamment du plan d'investissement
qui a été annoncé sur la période 2010
vous comprendrez que l'élu des yvelines
que je suis insiste tout
particulièrement sur la nécessité d'une
stratégie globale et coordonnée avec les
collectivités territoriales dans tous
les programmes d'aménagement conduit
dans ce cadre chez moi à conflans sainte
honorine
nous menons l'opération d'intérêt
national porte de paris qui doit
s'insérer dans des enjeux majeurs de
développement du trafic et de
renforcement de la scène en tant qu'axe
principal des changes depuis
l'atlantique vers le reste de l'europe
et bien sûr inversement sur ces points
vitaux pour lesquelles je le répète nous
partageons les mêmes objectifs
le groupe socialiste déposera des
amendements visant à la précision et
l'amélioration du texte
nous voulons d'une part comme je viens
de le dire nous assurer que
l'établissement nouvellement créée par
le texte conserve dans ses missions une
obligation de respect des territoires de
leurs activités de leur cohérence
très concrètement en veillant à la
compatibilité des opérations
d'aménagement avec les scot qui ont été
votées localement par les collectivités
territoriales concernées
nous voulons d'autre part dissiper un
malentendu que pourrait comporter le
projet de loi ainsi rédigé qui ne doit
pas perdurer
vous verrez que si nous ne sommes pas
hostiles par principe à ce que le nouvel
établissement puisse procéder à la
création de filiales et à des prises de
participations nos amendements
permettront de beaucoup mieux les
encadrer légalement afin d'écarter toute
tentation d'en faire une activité de
pure valorisation foncière et
immobilière
ce ne serait pas là vous en conviendrez
une attribution correcte des missions
assignées à un établissement de
promotion et d'exploitation notre réseau
fluvial
mais nous reviendrons à tout cela dans
le détail au cours de la discussion par
article bien entendu je veux maintenant
dire quelques mots du coeur du projet de
loi que constitue le regroupement des
personnels publics et privés au sein de
vnf sur ce sujet nous sommes très clairs
c'est le respect absolu du dialogue
social qui doit toujours prévaloir et
donc les accords qui ont été négociée et
acceptée par les syndicats
représentatifs parmi les points qui ont
été mises en avant à juste titre par les
syndicats il ya bien évidemment le
respect de la double représentation au
sein du comité technique unique comme du
conseil d'administration des personnels
de droit public d'une part et des
personnels de droit privé d'autre part
nous refuserions à l'évidence une fusion
des personnels à marche forcée comme
votre gouvernement n'a malheureusement
conduit dans une désastreuse conditions
et avec de déplorable résultats dans
certains cas comme celui de pôle emploi
en particulier
aussi le groupe socialiste sera
extrêmement vigilant sur ces points tout
au long de la discussion avec nos amis
et partenaires
nous savons que les difficultés
juridiques ont été soulevées par le
conseil d'état dans la transcription
textuelle de l'accord mais nous
veillerons à ce que les demandes des
organisations syndicales les engagements
pris auprès d'elle par le gouvernement
soient strictement et rigoureux
je mens respecter voilà en quelques mots
l'esprit qui anime les sénateurs
socialistes et leurs amis dans l'examen
du projet de loi qui nous est soumis
état d'esprit constructif enthousiaste
sur la nécessité de développement du
transport fluvial est un esprit
attentifs au devenir des personnels qui
en auront la charge dans la nouvelle
entité vigilant sur le respect intègre
du dialogue social
exigeant sur les missions de service
public et seulement de service public
que remplir à lagence vous le voyez nous
sommes ouverts à la discussion et à
l'amélioration de ce texte
ceci je reconnus engagé anciens merci de
votre attention
merci mon cher collègue
la parole est maintenant à madame
mireille schurch pour le groupe
communiste républicain et citoyen merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission monsieur le rapporteur
le présent projet de loi suivi et il est
une étape cruciale a dit madame la
ministre
mais il a suivi une route sinueuse avant
d'être débattu devant notre hémicycle
entre le projet initial avancé par le
gouvernement jusqu'au texte débattu ici
il y à vrai dire plus grand chose en
commun
ainsi c'est en prenant appui à la
dispositions votées lors de la loi dit
du grenelle de l'environnement relatives
à l'étude de la pertinence du transfert
en pleine propriété des voies navigables
à vnf que le gouvernement a initié sa
réflexion concernant la refonte du cadre
organisationnel du secteur des voies
navigables ce secteur comporte en effet
une particularité institutionnel avec
l'existence d'un epic vnf qui dispose de
380 agents et 4500 agents de l'état mis
à disposition de cet établissement
public
cette particularité constitue selon le
gouvernement une anomalie mettant à mal
l'efficacité de ce service la volonté
qui a prévalu
l'élaboration de ce texte est donc celle
de l'unification des personnels au sein
d'une structure unique en dehors et
comme le souligner notre rapporteur de
toute considération en termes de
missions du nouvel établissement et de
tout effort pour la relance de la voie
d'eau ce projet de loi est donc avant
tout celui de la gouvernance
cette question a pourtant toute son
importance et mérite que nous
l'examinions sérieusement ainsi la
démarche initiale du gouvernement a bien
été opéré dans une logique libérale
d'externalisation des missions de
service public voire à terme leur
privatisation cela n'a d'ailleurs à
aucun moment trompé les syndicats
ainsi de manière très claire la nouvelle
organisation revêtent également aux yeux
de ses partisans avantage non
négligeable de permettre une
optimisation des ressources affectées à
la voie d'eau on se situe dans ce cadre
bien loin de toute relance de la voie
d'eau de la révolution écologique prônée
par le ministre de l'époque pour se
trouver pieds et mains liés aux
politiques de rigueur et d'austérité
aussi nous souhaitons saluer ici les
avancées considérables obtenu par le
protocole d'accord en date du 24 juin
entre le ministère et les trois
organisations syndicales représentatives
des personnels de l'état et du 1er
juillet avec vnf
concernant la préservation des droits
des personnels dans le nouvel
établissement public
le gouvernement a par ailleurs reculé
sur la constitution de nouvelles agences
ou forme épique pour privilégier celle
de l'établissement public administratif
nous sommes en accord avec cette
évolution pendant cette évolution
correspondant à l'affectation normal de
personnels fonctionnaires et ouvriers
des parcs et ateliers de l'équipement au
demeurant vis-à-vis du besoin de
cohérence de l'ensemble des acteurs de
la voie d'eau et au regard des missions
de service public de cet établissement
nous considérons que la forme la plus
adaptée est bien celle d'un
établissement public administratif et ce
y compris au regard des compétences
marginal de cette agence en termes de
réglementation et de police de
navigation nous sommes également
satisfaits que l'état renonce par cet
accord au transfert des voix mais
également à la fermeture de voies
navigables
il s'agit d'un acquis précieux nous
sommes en effet particulièrement attaché
à l'unicité et à l'intégrité du réseau
des réseaux de transport en général
qu'ils soient ferroviaire ou fluviaux
car il s'agit là de l'élément clé
d'aménagement du territoire qui
conditionne ensuite la qualité du
service et son niveau d'ambition sur le
fond comment appréhender toute évolution
ne serait ce qu institutionnel de la
voie d'eau en dehors des enjeux de raids
x de réduction des émissions de gaz à
effet de serre et donc du développement
des transports alternatifs à la route
conformément aux objectifs de la loi du
grenelle de l'environnement
je pourrais à ce titre évoqué également
les autres enjeux liés au développement
de la voie d'eau comme la gestion de la
ressource aquatique notamment de la
régulation des plantes d'eau pour
assurer l'équilibré hydraulique et
hydrologiques du système complexe des
voix et cours d'eau ou des questions
relatives à la préservation de la
biodiversité
pour concrétiser cette ambition des
pistes étaient évoqués notamment par
l'article 11 de la loi grenelle
indiquant que le réseau fluvial
magistral ferait l'objet d'un plan de
restauration et de modernisation dont le
montant financier devrait être
clairement établis mais de cela il n'est
point question dans nos débats et nous
le regrettons
comme nous le pensons tous le principal
problème qui affecte la voie d'eau est
bien celle du sous-investissement
chronique qui la frappe et qui a conduit
un délabrement du réseau est
principalement des digues
ainsi selon un diagnostic mené par vnf
une part importante des ouvrages est
aujourd'hui en fin de vie ou une qualité
fonctionnelle médiocre 54% des écluses
et 63% des barrages présente au moins un
risque majeur de dégradations de
performance et un risque important de
perte complète de fonctions assurer la
performance du réseau est ainsi
fragilisé est insuffisante pour offrir
le niveau de sécurité de fonctionnement
hydraulique et la qualité de service
indispensable au développement du
transport fluvial à 7 à cette étape je
vous ferai aussi remarquer que nous
comprenons mieux pourquoi au travers des
lois de décentralisation l'état a voulu
se départir sur les collectivités au
moins pour le réseau dit secondaire de
ce fardeau devenu trop lourd à porter il
faut dire ici que les tentatives
d'expérimentations menées mais au moins
en lumière un élément celui de
l'importance des investissements
réalisés déjà simplement pour entretenir
ce réseau et plus encore pour le
régénérer concernant les engagements
financiers nous actons les annonces
d'investissements à hauteur de 840
millions d'investissements dans les
voies d'eau d'ici 2013 la ministre vient
d'en faire état à l'instant mais nous
serons extrêmement vigilants sur le
provisionnement concret de ces crédits
notamment dans le cadre de la loi de
finances nous sommes en effet
malheureusement habitués à ce que des
annonces fracassantes de la part du
gouvernement ne soit finalement que peu
suivies d'effet je tiens aussi à
rappeler que d'ici 2018
d'après le schéma national des
infrastructures de transport ce sont
plus de 2,5 milliards qui devrait être
investie dans la génération des voies
navigables pour le développement à grand
gabarit des trois liaisons seine nord
europe brno jean saône moselle et saône
rhin comment réussir ce tour de force
alors même que les ressources des
collectivités comme celle de l'état sont
restreintes par les politiques
gouvernementales
nous craignons alors le renforcement du
recours aux partenariats public-privé
types de marchés publics alléchant alors
même que les collectivités se retrouvent
asphyxiés pourtant et nous déposerons un
amendement sur ce thème les partenariats
public privé ont fait la démonstration
qu'il constituait au final une sorte de
miroir aux alouettes qui loin de
soulager les collectivités se révéler
sur le long terme une forme de marchés
publics plus coûteuse que les marchés
traditionnels tout en laissant craindre
pour la sécurité des infrastructures des
personnels et des usagers
ceci sans compter la perte de
compétences de la maîtrise d'ouvragé
publique
nous sommes à ce titre défavorable
recours à cette forme de marché qui met
à mal le principe d'unité du réseau par
une privatisation des infrastructures
mais revenons maintenant au coeur de
cette loi je vous le disais la volonté
initiale du gouvernement de
libéralisation et externalisation c'est
ici confronté très directement avec le
mouvement social du printemps dernier
d'ailleurs je tiens ici à vous alerter
sur le signal particulièrement négatif
qui serait envoyé aux agents de l'état
des grands la nouvelle structure si le
nom avancé et reconnue dans les
protocoles d'accord n'était pas celui
retenu par la loi vous nous parler
monsieur le rapporteur de psychologie
mais les symboles sont importants
en effet la grande majorité des
personnels de cette nouvelle agence
seront des fonctionnaires ouvriers des
parcs et ateliers qui ne souhaitait pas
être simplement aspiré par voies
navigables de france
je vous incite donc en la matière
la prudence et je dépose donc un premier
amendement sur ce sujet nous considérons
également que le texte nous est soumis
aujourd'hui et suite aux travaux de la
commission doit encore évoluer pour que
cette unification des services des pas
des considérations organisationnel tout
en respectant les acquis des différents
agents pour aller vers un renforcement
des missions de service public confiée à
cette agence
pour cette raison nous continuons de
porter en sciences est devant vous les
exigences que nous avons porté en
commission celles ci sont de deux ordres
haute en terme de statut des personnels
et de leurs représentations que les
missions de service public
sur le premier point par respect pour le
modèle choisi est celui de l'est pas
nous souhaitons supprimer tout élément
qui ferait de cet établissement un
établissement public suez generis qui
sont à nos yeux des éléments de
fragilisation de ce statut et de
contentieux à l'inversé même des
considérations qui ont prévalu à la
naissance de ce texte
plus largement nous souhaitons pas nos
amendements également interdire pour
l'avenir tout recrutement de personnels
contractuels de droit de droit privé et
ce conformément principes reconnus y
compris de manière jurisprudentielle
selon lequel les besoins permanents de
n'est pas doivent être pourvus par des
agents de droit public
nous considérons par ailleurs que le
regroupement des personnels au sein de
l'ehpad doit être l'occasion d'une
clarification des missions de service
public en conformité avec les
engagements du grenelle
ainsi si nous souhaitons que la part
dans le transport de marchandises des
modes alternatifs à la route atteignent
25 % il faut donner les moyens ce nouvel
établissement de remplir ses missions
pour cette raison la première des
mesures devraient être celles de stopper
l'hémorragie de la rgpp dans ce secteur
en effet depuis 20 ans nous pouvons que
regretter la perte de 2000 emplois dans
le secteur des voies navigables qui a
trop longtemps été considéré comme l'un
des secteurs clé de contraction et de
restriction des personnels publics les
objectifs d'ailleurs pour la période
2011 2013
sont à ce titre éloquent puisqu'il prône
la suppression de 271 emplois équivalent
temps plein nous y sommes pour notre
part opposée par ailleurs nous voulons
par nos amendements réitéré l'importance
d'une complémentarité renforcé avec les
modes ferroviaire et maritime
il serait en effet incohérent de penser
le développement fluvial en concurrence
avec le ferroviaire ou le maritime
à ce titre je voudrais rappeler aux
rapporteurs contrairement à ce qu'il a
été
il a indiqué en commission est ce que
j'ai entendu depuis le début de cette
séance que l'ensemble des voies d'eau du
réseau magistral ou secondaires peuvent
être utilisés pour le transport fret
dédié le réseau secondaire exclusivement
au tourisme et à ce titre un non sens
pour le respect des objectifs du
grenelle
nous avons également souhaité poser en
commission la question de la sécurité
des installations tant en ce qui
concerne les digues que les ouvrages
hydrauliques
nous sommes satisfaits que cette
préoccupation est été reprise dans le
texte
il en va de même pour les missions
d'intérêt général de bonne gestion et de
ressources aquatiques
nous sommes également satisfaits que le
rapporteur et repris la proposition que
nous avions fait de faire figurer dans
les missions d'établissement la
conservation du patrimoine qu'il soit
bâti ou paysager al'inverse nous restons
circonspects sur la possibilité offerte
par la présente loi pour la nouvelle
agence de pouvoir valoriser dans le
domaine public qui lui est confié que
son domaine privé en procédant à des
opérateurs à des opérations
d'aménagement complémentaires à ses
missions par le recours à la création de
filiales
nous craignons que cet élargissement de
ses missions reviennent à sortir le
nouvel établissement de son coeur de
métier d'autre part nous craignons que
la valorisation du domaine par le biais
de filiales privées n'aboutisse au final
à une faculté donnée à lagence d'une
privatisation des installations et de
leur dépendance comme de leur gestion
nous déposons un amendement sur cette
question afin donc
dre cette possibilité à la participation
dans des opérations d'intérêt général et
avec des acteurs publics sous contrôle
personnes morales de droit public
de manière plus générale et comme nous
le mentionnions dans ce début
d'intervention nous souhaitons que
l'état et la fif tu apportes al'agence
les moyens de son développement et de la
réalisation des missions de service
public
cela passe notamment par des concours
financiers à hauteur des actions et
projets prévus pour les voies navigables
par le schéma national des
infrastructures de transport nous
attendons ainsi que les engagements
financiers pris soit honorée il s'agit
là de l'élément fondamental pour une
relance effective de la voie d'eau
concernant l'ensemble du débat qui a eu
lieu en commission et aura probablement
lieu ici en séance sur les modalités de
représentation des personnels au sein de
comités techniques et ce suite à l'avis
du conseil d'état et du conseil
constitutionnel en date du 28 juillet
2001 qui ont conduit à la réécriture du
projet de loi no 2011
nous estimons qu'il est important de
conserver une structure unique pour
l'ensemble des personnels dans ce cadre
l'amendement prévu en commission par le
rapporteur semblait concilier plusieurs
exigences respect des protocoles
d'accord constitutionnalité de la mesure
proposée et structure unique ayant la
souplesse nécessaire pour s'adapter aux
situations différentes entre les
différents personnels nous espérons donc
que le texte pourra évoluer
favorablement en séance et nous en
sommes persuadés
nous avons également au travers de nos
amendements souhaité intégrer dans notre
réflexion
l'association des usagers des voies
d'eau pour par la création de comités de
service aux usagers telle que proposée
par les syndicats de la batellerie au
regard des incertitudes qui pèsent
encore sur l'évolution du présent texte
nous attendrons bien sûr le débat en
séance avant de nous procès se prononcer
sur le sens de notre vote
nous espérons que nos amendements
portent ont des exigences sur les
missions de service public de
l'établissement pourront être
adoptez les sénateurs de mon groupe ne
cesseront en effet d'affirmer la
nécessité d'un service public de la voie
d'eau de qualité
fort d'une ingénierie publique de moyens
renforcés modernisé au sein du nouvel
établissement capable ainsi de résister
aux logiques de privatisation de
morcellement du réseau et finalement de
son abandon pour défaut de rentabilité
économique
merci de votre attention merci ma chère
collègue
la parole est maintenant à monsieur
christian bourquin pour le groupe en un
rassemblement démocratique social et
européen
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues le projet
de loi relatif à l'agencé nationale des
voies navigables répond à deux objectifs
remédier aux problèmes de gouvernance
qui handicape rétablissement en charge
depuis 1991 de l'essentiel du réseau
fluvial de notre pays
ainsi qu'élargir les missions du nouvel
établissement que voulait lui substituer
ma collègue françoise laborde évoquera
en complément de mon propos les
dispositions inscrites dans ce projet de
loi
toutefois en préalable il ya un abîme
merkel ne faut pas tomber qu'il faut
éviter à tout prix n'en faisons pas ne
créons pas un nouveau rss
je laisse cela de côté et pour ma part
je souhaiterais ici sur le permettait de
tribunes parlait surtout de la incidente
question du financement des missions du
futur établissement qui d'ailleurs sont
passés sous silence
dans ce texte et qui met d'ores et déjà
en suspens les objectifs ambitieux
sommes pourtant ait été donné ce projet
de loi est d'une importance capitale
on l'entend bien pour l'avenir de nous
voir est navigable car il s'agit avant
tout des économies et donc et surtout
d'emplois mais il s'agit aussi d'honorer
les engagements issus du grenelle 1 de
l'environnement qui a fait du secteur
fluvial ne pourrai était absolue dans la
lutte contre les émissions de gaz à
effet de serre le point d'orgue
de cette modernisation voulue à grande
échelle consiste à la construction d'un
canal seine-nord prévu opérationnel en
2014 pour un montant estimé à 4
milliards 2 mais monsieur ministre
est-ce que vous et votre gouvernement
n'avait réellement l'intention car j'ai
noté que les trois régions françaises
nord picardie nord pas de calais
picardie le france était au rendez vous
financier qu'aujourd'hui vous n'avez pas
confirmé la présence de l'état d'une
façon concrète et donc sur ce projet de
loi sur ces finales sont attendues
encore faut-il que les financements
potentiels ne se fasse pas au détriment
de la réalisation de chantiers
antérieure à commencer par la seule
remise en état du réseau fluvial
magistral estimé à un milliard et demi
d'euros
que penser dans ces conditions d'un
projet de loi qui élargit les missions
de voies navigables de france
un homme a nommé temps de renforcer ses
moyens financiers
l'exemple désolant du canal du midi
illustre fort bien ce qui peut en
résulter
trop longtemps l'état s'est désintéressé
de l'entretien de son patrimoine fluvial
il a laissé s'installer une situation
juridique complexe propre à empêcher
toute coopération sérieuse dans
l'intérêt du canal le canal du midi est
en effet malade
ces platanes bicentenaires ont été
dessinés par le chancre coloré entre le
moment où voies navigables de france a
identifié ce champignon est le moment où
il se résout à l'abattage il s'est
écoulé six ans ce sont désormais les
42000 platanes qui bordent le canal qui
sont condamnés d'ailleurs le président
de la république à de cet été est venu
nous dire je ne suis pas le président
des platanes
il s'en est vite ravisé il a confié jo
les notés à madame la ministre est donc
à vous monsieur le ministre
une mission tendant à récupérer tout
cela mais je constate que rien n'a
avancé
j'ai envie de vous dire attention
messieurs ministre parce que le prêt
public qui reviennent dans le lot de
mardi et il sera à côté des platanes de
nouveau parce que le canal du midi passe
dans l'aude et il sera tout à côté
bon au delà du sujet des platanes qui
est un problème important est évident
l'état a par ailleurs laissé en plus
certaines berges du canal s'effondrer et
bon nombre d'éclusés fermé tout cela
faute d'entretien
au total ce magnifique ouvrage décidé
par louis xiv est distingué je cite en
tant qu'une des réalisations les plus
extraordinaires du génie civil de l'art
moderne se voit menacé de déclassement
au patrimoine mondial de l'unesco
l'estimation du coût de sa
réhabilitation dans un premier temps
évalué à 100 millions d'euros s'élève
désormais à 200 millions d'euros la
moitié devant permettre l'abattage des
arbres et leurs plantations l'autre la
réparation des ouvrages
certains ont pourtant avancé l'idée au
risque d'organiser une confusion des
rôles
ils ont avancé l'idée que l'état
pourrait venir au secours des
collectivités locales concernées pour
les aider à sauver le canal du midi
or je suis ministre le canal du midi
y compris dans sa partie languedocienne
devenu conséquemment consécutivement à
la l'option des lois des 13 juillet 2003
et 13 août 2004 réseau régional à
vocation touristique
il demeure sous la responsabilité de
l'état et les solutions d'intervention
le concernant continue à revenir à voies
navigables de france établissement
public placé sous son autorité exclusive
celle de l'état ainsi la région en gros
si on avait l'honneur de présider à
l'exécutif attend de l'état qu'il assume
sa responsabilité pleine et entière sur
ce dossier profondément attaché au
sauvetage du canal du midi
nous n'en sommes pas moins opposée à
payer pour les différences et l'incurie
de l'état
il ya un mot qu'on cale volontarisme
mari de ma région ne peut être remis en
cause quand il s'agit pour elle
d'exercer ses propres compétences dans
un cadre contractuel structurés j'en
veux pour preuve
tu ministre l'investissement de 30
millions qu'elle a réalisé pour
l'amélioration des capacités du canal du
rhône à sète qui relie la méditerranée
par le port de sète au bassin ronson et
le port de laudun-l'ardoise un jeu
majeur pour la russie en matière de
transport de marchandises il fait partie
intégrante sa stratégie tournée vers le
développement des modes de transports
alternatifs à la route et participe
également au rayonnement du port de sète
est aujourd'hui la région récolte le
fruit de ses efforts les trafics du port
de sète sont à progression les
industriels suivent pourquoi monsieur le
ministre ne pas donner au canal du midi
les mêmes chances que celui de 7
cela impliquerait une harmonisation du
statut juridique du canal sur toute sa
longueur sur toute sa longueur est de
rendre possible une contractualisation
global l'état assumerait ses
responsabilités sa part ce qui
permettrait aux collectivités concernées
collectivités locales concernées devenir
l'appuyer et simplement l'appuyer dans
le respect de leurs compétences monsieur
le ministre j'ai souvent saisis madame
la ministre toutes ces questions je les
fais par écrit à plusieurs reprises elle
n'a pas eu encore le temps de me
répondre
et donc je profite l'examen de ce projet
de loi pour vous interpeller
si vous considérez qu'il faut changer la
loi on pourrait être tous d'accord c'est
le moment
si vous considérez qu'une autre solution
est possible
c'est aussi le moment de le dire c'est
pour ça qu'avec mon groupe rdse
nous attendrons vos réponses pour nous
positionner sur ce sujet majeur
merci merci mon cher collègue la parole
est maintenant à notre collègue alain
chatillon rattaché au groupe pour une
union
un mouvement populaire monsieur le
président madame monsieur le ministre
chers collègues
mon intervention sur les voies
navigables le canal du midi tient
notamment mes mandats de maire de revel
et de président de la communauté de
communes lauragais revel sorézois et je
voudrais remercier mon collègue
précédent qui a déjà enfoncé le clou sur
le canal du midi
allez espérons que sa collègue fera de
même tout à l'heure il est temps qu'on
parle enfin un peu de notre midi c'est
le minimum car certes mais ce midi
toulousain nous situe en effet aux
sources du canal du midi quatre communes
de notre intercommunalité ce bar à ce
partage le barrage de saint ferréol pour
l'histoire je rappelle que c'est pierre
paul riquet ingénieur né à béziers
fermiers des gabelles qui a réussi à
ramener les eaux de l'est et de l'ouest
de notre montagne noire pour alimenter
le bassin du canal du midi et notamment
ce fameux saint ferriol capacité de 7
millions de mètres cubes et donner ainsi
naissance au canal du midi pour
rejoindre l'atlantique à la méditerranée
en utilisant la navigation sur la
garonne pour la partie ouest le canal du
midi fut inaugurée avec faste en 1681
par certes louis xiv et colbert mais je
rappelle que c'est quand même riquet qui
en est l'instigateur
il était décédé un an auparavant
après avoir engagé sa fortune
personnelle être mort hui d mais un an
après colbert attiré bien sûr toutes les
avant tout les avantages en estimant que
c'était lui qui l'avait fait d'autres
bassins d'alimentation des sikhs ont
aussi complété depuis les apports
anneaux pour l'alimentation du canal du
midi au seuil de naurouze point le plus
haut du partage des eaux avec le soutien
du conseil régional de midi pyrénées de
l'union européenne du fonds national
d'aménagement du développement et du
territoire et du département de la haute
garonne
je suis à l'origine de la création de ce
musée et jardins du canal du midi
sur ce magnifique site de saint ferriol
mais ce site
monsieur le ministre il est géré par un
sivom syndicat intercommunal à vocation
multiple
fort de quatre communes situées sur
trois départements et deux régions
vous imaginez la simplicité
administrative que cela proposer
d'autant que nous avons ensuite une
convention de superposition avec voies
navigables de france
alors quelles sont nos sujets
d'inquiétude et quelles sont vos
attentes
la gestion de ce site historique nous
amène au constat de la dégradation au
fil du temps du service rendu par voies
navigables de france et ce malgré
l'impulsion je dois signaler de marc
papinutti son directeur général qui
depuis quelques mois à engager un
dialogue constructif mais j'espère qu'il
sera suivi d'effets vnf gère exploiter
développe le plus grand réseau européen
de voies navigables
certes cependant elle délaisse
l'entretien des berges l'entretien des
parcs des arbres et en particulier sur
le canal du midi ou comme elle l'a dit
tout à l'heure mon collègue 42000
platanes sont atteints par le chancre et
cela fait c'est en septembre que nous
attendons effectivement que l'on commet
ses travaux ce sera un véritable
sinistre
quand effectivement il faudra arracher
tous ces platanes en même temps que va
devenir ce site classé essentiellement
touristique
s'il est privé de ses arbres à titre
d'exemple comment faire face à la
suppression progressive des postes
d'agent d'entretien
je cite un exemple entre le la prise à
doha où la montagne noire et le seuil de
naurouze
il y avait 35 personnes qui assurait
l'entretien il y a quelques années il
n'y a plus que neuf aujourd'hui comment
gérer les écluses du canal du midi où
circulent seulement quelques bateaux de
plaisance s'il n'ya plus d'éclusier
sachant portant qu'un regroupement des
embarcations pendant quelques heures
permettent aujourd'hui de limiter la
consommation en eau n'oubliez pas chers
collègues que le canal du midi ses 700
mètres cubes d'eau à chaque écluse 40%
de l'eau sur le canal du midi s'évapore
les ragondins notamment au delà des
prises d'eau
contrôler il va falloir donc entretenir
ses berges à la fois du canal du midi et
du bassin de saint ferriol de plus en
plus et rodez et entretenir le parc
autour du dac procéder au remplacement
des arbres dans les plantations sur le
canal du midi dans le cadre d'un plan à
dix quinze ans sachant que ces sites
sont un atout touristique majeur de
proximité pour les régions midi pyrénées
et languedoc roussillon
en un mot la question qui se pose est
celle du statut du canal du midi
doit-il rester et dans quelles
conditions d'envoi navigables de france
bien qu'il ne constituent plus
aujourd'hui une alternative
je dis bien aujourd'hui aux transports
il à vis de la route ou vis-à-vis du
rail il convient d'entreprendre une
véritable analyse pour répondre à ce
sujet de préoccupation pour nos deux
régions et les communes traversées et le
projet de loi qui nous est soumis ma
paraît relativement cohérent concernant
les vnf de substitution voie ferrée
routes et autoroutes en dehors bien sûr
du canal du midi est particulièrement
dès lors que les syndicats des
personnels acceptent les évolutions qui
leur sont proposés nous ne pouvons moins
en ce qui me concerne qu'exprimer en
accord avec les propositions formulées
je salue également les engagements pris
lors du dernier conseil des ministres du
31 août par le premier ministre et
madame ministre l'écologie dû
développement durable en faveur de
l'environnement
en effet ils ont précisé qu'au delà du
transport fluvial et de la gestion
hydraulique
l'action de vnf seraient tenus de
s'inscrire dans la continuité du
grenelle de l'environnement tout en
favorisant l'aménagement du territoire
l'autorisent monsieur vial et les
activités nautiques
ce ministre simplement il va falloir
passer des prouesses aux actes et faire
en sorte que nous puissions
véritablement voir sur le terrain la
réalité de ses promesses
cela répond à certaines de mes
interrogations mais encore faut-il que
ces orientations soient financés et mise
en application par vnf j'appelle
attention également de madame le
ministre est de vous monsieur le
ministre sur la nécessité de conserver
le nom le sigle voies navigables de
france
on ne change pas une marque quand elle a
20 ans et il faut savoir qu'aujourd'hui
cette marque existe alors ne la change
ont pas parce que ça peut coûter très
cher sur le plan touristique
pour toutes ces raisons je souhaitais
madame le ministre monsieur le ministre
une étude spécifique soit consacrée au
canal du midi en liaison étroite avec
des collections des collectivités
locales et bien entendu les régions et
les départements pour appréhender ces
particularités par rapport aux autres
voies navigables de france
faut-il ou pas remettre à niveau ce
canal du midi pour en faire un axe de
transport
faut-il destiné essentiellement et
uniquement tourisme quels moyens va-t-on
prendre pour économiser l'eau
carlo va devenir une denrée rare et cher
donc soyons économe car nous avons le
devoir également de conserver ce joyau
inscrit au patrimoine mondial de
l'unesco que l'histoire ait l'audace des
hommes nous ont légué monsieur le
président madame la ministre monsieur le
ministre
chers collègues merci pour votre écoute
attentive et l'accueil que vous
réserverez à mon propos merci mon chaque
collègue
la parole est maintenant à monsieur
robert navarro
pour le groupe socialiste europe
écologie les verts
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
président monsieur le rapporteur mes
chers collègues vous le savez ce texte a
été adopté en conseil des ministres le
31 août dernier
depuis les élections sénatoriales se
sont déroulés fin septembre ce qui fait
que nous avons dû travailler très vite
premier élément de réflexion ce texte ne
traite que de la gouvernance du fluvial
il regroupe dans un même ensemble les
agents de droit public et les agents de
droit privé qui travaillent
l'exploitation et à l'entretien et au
développement des voies navigables
c'est un sujet certes intéressant et
surtout en particulier pour les agents
concernés mais nous passons à côté de
l'essentiel pour notre industrie et
notre économie
face à la crise nous devons repenser
notre modèle de développement
les transports sont la clé d'une relance
de notre économie
on ne peut déconnecter de réflexion sur
les voies navigables de celle sur les
ports maritimes sur notre industrie et
au delà sur notre place dans la
mondialisation
tous ces sujets sont liés et absente ce
texte dans une économie où la place des
échanges et centrale si vous êtes à
l'écart du réseau de communication et de
circulation des biens et des
marchandises
votre territoire n'est pas attractif
investir dans le fluvial mieux penser
les liens du fluvial du maritime
c'est augmenter l'attractivité de nos
territoires
la massification de la desserte fluviale
est un enjeu économique et écologique
pour les ports français
tous les grands ports européens g
on développer ce mode de transport
alternatif pour faire face à l'afflux
des marchandises
je les dis en commission je souhaite
rappeler ici un convoi fluvial le
transporter 350 deux containers un train
80 en camion 2 malgré ces évidences nous
voie navigable souffre d'un déficit
chronique d'investissements et
d'entretien
ce texte ne
rien car il ne peut rien et c'est bien
dommage
certes cette année vnf va disposer de 70
millions supplémentaires mais ce qui est
présenté comme un doublement des crédits
relève de la fumisterie face aux passifs
le retard accumulé
après des décennies de
sous-investissement et sous entretien
colis cette somme est insuffisante pour
ne pas dire ridicule ce texte également
accompagné d'un programme
d'investissement défini par vnf qui se
monte à 840 millions entre 2010 et 2013
face à l'état lamentable de 8,5 km de
voies navigables dont 2600 km dédiée au
fret
cette somme est également insuffisante
j'ai suivi hier une partie du chiffre
d'une certaine ump sur notre programme
et les chiffres fantaisistes annoncé en
plus de 500 milliards de dette due au
seul nicolas sarkozy depuis 2007
nous devons chiffrer les conséquences de
vos économies de bouts de chandelles
mené sans discernement pour les voies
navigables
le coût de votre mauvaise gestion c'est
de mon point de vue un milliard celle
d'euros cherche il affirmé qu'il faut
toujours saisi l'occasion d'une crise
pour changer ce qu'il faut changer
eh bien monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre monsieur le rapporteur mes
chers collègues je vous invite à
renverser la partie mortel pour notre
pays de la crise que nous affrontons
nous devons lancer une remise en état
sincère et ambitieuse à la clé d'un tel
programme nous avons d'abord les emplois
dédiés à la rénovation les emplois
indirects
par la suite nous avons la croissance
grâce à l'attractivité de notre
territoire
le fluvial par les containers ses 30% du
trafic à rotterdam
quand pour ça en l'air contre 4,7 à
marseille et 9 au havre en conclusion je
souhaiterais revenus
sur ce qui a bien défendu mon président
bourquin tout à l'heure je vais parler
aussi monsieur le maire de revel du
canal du midi
l'autre atout maître de mon point de vue
de notre réseau fluvial
c'est le tourisme notre pays la première
destination touristique au monde et le
canal du midi appartient aux joyaux de
notre patrimoine
nous allons parler de 12 juillet dernier
nous sommes toujours sous la menace le
rapport négatif de l'unesco sans me
donner de chiffres
vous êtes engagés dans le contrat de
performance entre l'état et vnf
d'importants moyens soient dégagés pour
le canal du midi avec notamment des
travaux de traitement des deee
l'automatisation des excuses et de
gestion des plantations
nous connaissons l'enveloppé globale
global 840 millions sur la période 2010
cette enveloppe est très insuffisante
pour la remise à niveau de l'ensemble du
réseau comme bien l'état qu'on te dit
maître monsieur le ministre pour venir
soit l'incurie qui frapperait le canal
du midi depuis des décennies pour rappel
ça a été dit le remplacement des
platanes et ses 5 millions d'euros ces
platanes ne sont pas seulement un
élément fort du paysage du midi l'espèce
avait été choisie sous napoléon iii pour
sa capacité à retenir la terre des verts
pourrait par l ouvrage c'est encore 5
millions d'euros 200 millions d'euros au
total
les collectivités allons à ces messieurs
les ministres de pays à la place de
l'état
on vous l'a déjà dit mon prix dans
bouquet vous l'a dit en languedoc
roussillon
nous défendons la décentralisation mais
dans l'équité mais ceux des ministres
vous ne pouvez pas nous livrer un réseau
en ruine la volonté de l'état de
décentraliser le réseau secondaire est
donc de transférer un canal désormais à
l'abandon n'est pas acceptable tant que
le rattrapage historique n'est pas fait
notre région a toujours montré une
volonté sans faille ce dossier mais une
région ne peut remplacer des années
d'absence de l'état propriétaire
voilà pour conclure monsieur le ministre
face à vos responsabilités
le canal diminue constituent lé
des réalisations les plus
extraordinaires de l'ère moderne et a
ouvert la voie à révolution industrielle
faute d'entretien causent des pseudos
austérité menée sans discernement notre
patinoire et disparaît et notre avenir
économique est menacée
je vous demande de prendre des
dispositions pour que l'état assume ses
responsabilités de propriétaires est
fâché les investissements nécessaires
les responsables politiques ne sont que
des passeurs dépositaire de ce
patrimoine
vous n'avez pas le droit d'aligner à la
fois le passé et l'avenir des
générations qui nous suivent
vous avez les périodes de responsabilité
de transmettre ce patrimoine monsieur le
ministre je vous remercie